I'm just going to call it rise of the
apes I'm sick of saying the Rise of the
Planet of the Apes and I've cried just
in one man
so Rise of the Planet of the Apes stars
James Franco Frieda Pinto
John Lithgow Draco Malfoy Tom tom Felton
and Andy Serkis of Gollum and King Kong
Fame it's about a drug these scientists
are trying to create that supposedly
will cure Alzheimer's and they're
testing it on Apes and I don't really
want to spoil it for you but the main
ship Caesar through various ways gets
very smart off of this drug James Franco
kind of sneaks him out of the facility
and starts taking care of him at home
where they create this relationship with
each other
because of certain things also that I
don't want to spoil that happen he has
to then go to this facility and live
with other Apes which is at first very
hard for him they kind of start to think
you know what it's time to do something
it's time to bust out of here so as you
probably know this is a prequel to the
Charlton Heston movie in that film all
the Apes have already taken over this is
the film to show how that happened and
what led to it this is a great movie
this is an excellent movie this is a
really fun summer film I can't really
talk too much about other things without
just saying Andy Serkis is a brilliant
actor he's really animalistic he did
Gollum he did King Kong and now he's
doing this he is just the king of motion
capture acting he is fantastic Caesar
the character is one of the most
intriguing characters this year that I
have seen in a movie it shows that you
do not need dialog to be intriguing it's
all in your face and in your eyes Andy
Serkis owns this movie the James Franco
is very good I liked his performance a
lot he was convincing in his role Frieda
Pinto was fine she's very beautiful as
she was fine you know
John Lithgow is very good as well and
now the comedic performance at all the
special effects are astounding for these
Apes
they look so realistic I mean there are
a few shots or like is that really I
can't tell and because I can't tell that
is saying something right there once the
action really starts it's really fun and
exciting and really well directed some
of the stuff that happens in this movie
gave me chills at a few times some of
the things that happened I was like oh
wow I was not expecting that this movie
is shot in beautiful 2d and it's just so
wonderful this and cowboys and Aliens
both in 2d made me very happy I'm just
I'm very pleased
along with Caesar there's another really
awesome character it's like this
incredibly chill Jamaican orangutan that
just like hangs out with Caesar just
like stalks lemon stubbed it with
through sign language it's just so he's
awesome I love that guy and it seems
like Draco my tom felton is always a
jerk I'm afraid he's gonna start getting
typecast like this annoying little jerk
also be sure to stay for the credits
because not after the credits but in the
middle of the credits there is a scene
that honestly changed a huge opinion of
that I had about the film immediately I
was I was wanting something to be
explained a little bit more it was in
the end so state in the middle of the
end credits there's a sequence that is
very helpful I did have a couple
problems with the film one I felt that
it started just a teensy bit slow as
soon as things progressed with Caesar
and you got to know Caesar as a
character and he became integrated then
it really picked up I know the film is
really trying to portray the apes as the
main central story and it should be and
it's very well done that is just
riveting that gapes everything about the
Apes
I loved it that made a problem some of
the stuff with the humans and the human
drama and human aspects of the movie
weren't as entertaining to me as a stuff
of the Apes and so whenever it was away
from the Apes
I wasn't isn't
see I wasn't as interested it's so
inconsequential it just it it's such a
small tiny little thing with me and so
really I had a lot of fun with this
movement really revitalized the
franchise Tim Burton is thinking my gosh
what did I do
I'm gonna give rise of the Apes three
and a half out of four stars it is an
excellent movie I had a lot of phones
then just a few tiny little gripes
that's it and other than that I really
loved it so if you like this review
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes